[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
am fuß des eiffelturms das gesicht eines
siegers und auch von einem dem ein stein
vom herzen fällt weil er auf den letzten
metern bangen musste der präsident der
französischen republik heißt auch für
die nächsten fünf jahre emanuele makro
hallo und bosbach ihnen allen frankreich
hat gewählt der neue staatspräsident ist
der alte mit zweimal deutlichem aber
markus herausforderin marine le pen vom
weit rechten rand war ihm wesentlich
näher auf den fersen als beim letzten
mal und viele französinnen und franzosen
sind gar nicht erst zur wahl gegangen
dennoch ist das aufatmen bei der eu in
brüssel und im berliner kanzleramt jetzt
bis nach paris zu hören mindestens der
wahlabend bei unseren nachbarn anna
wendt hat den überblick
der alte ist der neue dem animago hat
erreicht was in den letzten 20 jahren
keinem seiner vorgänger vergönnt war
eine zweite amtszeit jubel und
erleichterung auf dem schon gemacht
ich wusste dass er wiedergewählt wird
aber ich hatte angst dass es noch
knapper wird
nun kann er sich weiter für ein starkes
europa einsetzen und seine reformen die
er bereits begonnen hat voranbringen
markus wichtigste aufgabe dürfte
allerdings darin bestehen das land zu
einen denn sein vorsprung vor le pen ist
geringer als vor fünf jahren als die
beiden sich schon einmal bei einer
stichwahl gegenüber standen im rechten
lager hatten nun viele auf ihren sieg
gehofft die unterlegene kandidatin zeigt
sich dennoch kämpferisch
das ergebnis repräsentiert auch für uns
einen sieg
millionen unserer mitbürger haben heute
für das nationale lager und für einen
wechsel gestimmt ihnen drücke ich meinen
dank aus
mehr als 40 prozent der französinnen und
franzosen haben für le pens rechtes
nationalistisches programm gestimmt in
den vergangenen jahren hat sie sich
etabliert als wählbare politische
alternative zu max
emanuel marco ist gescheitert insofern
als dass er marie le pen zu viel
freiraum gelassen hat so konnte sie sich
mit einem politischen angebot das
teilweise sogar fehlerhaft ist als
vertreterin der mittleren und unteren
einkommensschichten in szene setzen er
hat sich nicht mit deren fragen befasst
und sie hat diese lücke gefüllt
besonders im norden des landes fanden le
pens soziale versprechen viel zuspruch
eine region die von armut und
arbeitslosigkeit geprägt ist zwar wächst
frankreichs wirtschaft insgesamt doch
längst nicht bei allen kommt der
aufschwung an der erfolg von markus
zweite amtszeit wird daher davon
abhängen ob es ihm gelingt die
unzufriedenen und politikverdrossenen
einzufangen die enthaltung lag bei
dieser wahl auf rekordniveau
wir atmen heute abend auf das ganze land
war angespannt aber jetzt peile ich mich
ich will marco auf dem schon gemacht
hören
vor wenigen minuten ist marco hier am
eiffelturm eingetroffen will zu seinen
anhängern sprechen und gemeinsam mit
ihnen seine wiederwahl feiern
ja und genau da ist für uns thomas walde
thomas eine grandiose kulisse aber ist
das auch ein grandioser sieg
also man muss zunächst einmal sagen in
macau ist der erste präsident seit 20
jahren der es geschafft hat wieder
gewählt zu werden das ist in frankreich
eine selbstverständlichkeit er hat am
oberen ende der vorhersagen
abgeschnittene die prognosen hatten ihm
einen im besten fall sie ein solches
ergebnis vorausgesagt zwischendrin sah
so aus als könnte marine le pen das
gewinnen also von daher gibt es eine
große erleichterung es ist nicht mehr
der große aufbruch wie vor fünf jahren
bei seinen anhängern sondern man ist er
froh noch mal mit einem blauen auge
davon gekommen zu sein und ab morgen
muss man sich gedanken machen um die
parlamentswahlen die anstehen wie er
dort eine mehrheit zusammenbekommt damit
der innenpolitisch tatsächlich von
seiner agenda noch möglichst viel retten
möglichst viel umsetzen kann ja das
schließt ja gleich meine nächste frage
an was ist denn von makro jetzt zu
erwarten gibt es dann möglicherweise
schon erste hinweise in dem was er da
sagt hinter hin
[Applaus]
also er hat gerade eben gesagt ihm sei
sehr bewusst dass viele menschen ihn
gewählt haben vor allem um die extreme
rechte zu verhindern er sei sich dessen
bewusst man müsse jetzt liefern damit
die wut die unzufriedenheit im volk die
er sehr wohl gehört habe dass die jetzt
mündet in tatsächliche politik dass man
die mit praktischer politik angeht das
war das was er die letzten wochen die
letzten minuten verkauft ihr gesagt hat
wenn sie mögen wenn ihr mögt können wir
noch mal kurz reinhören ich übersetze
das so lange und dann geht ihr in mainz
einfach raus bist das zu lang wird
also gemeinsam wollen wir
wir werden versuchen die einheit
zu erreichen mit der wir besser leben
können in frankreich und die dinge
bewerkstelligen angehen die auf uns
warten
gemeinsam werden wir für die unsere
generation für die nächste generation
die kommen den dinge angehen können
okay ein kleiner ausschnitt meiner
landsleute der rede thomas ganz
herzlichen dank für den moment da war er
sehr abrupt weg aber wir gehen rüber zu
marine le pen und da diese kampagne
beobachtet unsere kollegin christas
christl marie le pen hat ihren abstand
auf makro halbiert verglichen mit den
beim letzten mal den verdankt sie dieses
doch sehr gute abschneiden
sie profitiert vor allem dingen davon
dass viele franzosen von makro
enttäuscht sind in erster angetreten vor
fünf jahren als hoffnungsträger und nun
ist es aber so dass vor allen dingen den
ländlichen gebieten in den kleineren
städten viele menschen den eindruck
haben dass sich überhaupt nichts
geändert hat und genau da hat marine le
pen angesetzt um diese zielgruppe
gezielt umworben und hat also auch die
gewisse bürgernähe gezeigt und es ist
sie gelungen zu zeigen dass sie die
sorgen und die ängste dieser menschen
ernst nimmt und sie hat den eindruck
erweckt dass dass sie durchaus eine ist
sie das auch durchsetzen umsetzen kann
und will was sie da verspricht und das
hat viele überzeugt und das wahlergebnis
hat auch gezeigt dass sie eben auch
stimmen von vielen anderen parteien aus
dem parteienspektrum bekommen hatte die
haben nicht für micron gewählt sondern
für marine le pen und deswegen ist sie
ebenso gut abgeschnitten wie sie
abgeschnitten hat christel wir erleben
heute ein gespaltenes frankreich und das
wird sich jetzt in den nächsten tagen
wochen monaten ja nicht einfach so legen
oder
nee das kann man nicht sagen das ist im
prinzip jetzt nur so ein bisschen eine
atempause wenn der das ressentiment
national die partei von marine le pen
ist ja mittlerweile eine ganz feste
größe in der französischen
parteienlandschaft und sie ist auch
salonfähig geworden also man muss sich
nicht mehr schämen wenn man sagt ich
wähle marine le pen und das ist ein
bisschen auch ihr verdienst sie hat die
partei die ja lange zeit so ein bisschen
die baath partei war enttäuscht und als
gemäßigt dargestellt obwohl das programm
relativ radikal ist aber sie gilt so ein
bisschen als gemäßigter hatten netten
toren und das kommt sehr gut an und
dieses gedankengut oder beziehungsweise
die überzeugung dass man eben auch
marine le pen wählen kann die hat sich
festgesetzt hier im land und das wird
nicht von einem tag auf den anderen
verschwinden zumal es ja am rechten rand
ja noch einen gibt der jetzt seinen
finger hebt nämlich erik sem und der hat
jetzt zwar nicht so wahnsinnig viele
stimmen eingefahren beim ersten wahlgang
aber der ist immer noch da und der wird
natürlich jetzt auch versuchen die leute
um sich zu scharen um eben dieses lager
zu festigen also auf jeden fall noch
viel zu besprechen herzlichen dank an
unser team in paris
das war eine wahl bei der auch europa
ganz genau hinschaut und mitunter den
atem anhält katarina barley spd ist
vizepräsidentin des eu-parlaments und
jetzt bei uns vor bayerische guten abend
sehen ist welche schlüsse muss dann
europa jetzt aus diesem wahlabend ziehen
reicht ein gerade noch mal gut gegangen
auf keinen fall wir sehen dass
frankreich ein gespaltenes landes das
ist richtig gesagt worden wir sehen aber
vor allen dingen dass sich der diskurs
sehr nach rechts verschoben hat
noch rechts von marine le pen gibt es
erik sem uhr der ist bereits erwähnt
worden der wirklich in deutschland
werden dass strafbare äußerungen von
sich gegeben hat rassistisch
menschenfeindlich und auch das wird
inzwischen salonfähig also insgesamt
haben wir eine pool ein politisches
klima in frankreich das uns haben
bereiten muss ja wir haben da jemanden
gesehen erlebt heute die ganze zeit
schon und heute mit einem noch relativ
guten ergebnis die ein völlig anderes
europa will als es derzeit existiert
auch als sie ist verkörpern vorbei sie
hat nicht schlecht abgeschnitten marine
le pen und sie ist definitiv keine
eintagsfliege was konkret muss ich denn
in europa jetzt ändern oder anders
gefragt kann europa sich leisten zu
hoffen dass nichts schief geht
also erstmal hat marine le pen deutlich
verloren und ich würde das auch betonen
wollen nach den vorberichten denn sie
hatte natürlich
angriffspunkte bei makro und die hat sie
nicht nutzen können deutlich nicht
nutzen können und
makro hat auch deshalb die wahl gewonnen
weil er sich so klar für europa
positioniert hat wir haben heute eine
weitere wahl gesehen in europa in
slowenien wo ein autokrat ein vertrauter
von viktor orban in ungarn deutlich
verloren hat also insgesamt haben wir
heute eine stärkung eine deutliche
stärkung der proeuropäischen kräfte
gesehen frau war aber im nächsten jahr
zeigen sie wenn ich sie ganz kurz
unterbrechen auf sie blicken jetzt schon
wieder das raus was man sagen kann okay
wir müssen eigentlich nichts ändern
läuft doch noch so halbwegs slowenien
haben sie gerade genannt ungarn haben
sie nicht genannt wo viktor orbán
ein wahlsieg errungen hat polen haben
sie nicht genannt es ist ja nicht nur
frankreich wo die menschen
offensichtlich probleme damit haben wie
dieses europa aufgestellt ist
naja und grant ist natürlich sehr
spezieller fall ne der ist da lässt man
seit zwölf jahren an einen autokraten
regieren und das land auf sich
maßschneidern
insgesamt muss man sagen was wir in
europa tun müssen ist wir müssen
sichtbarer werden und auch
schlagkräftiger werden einiger werden
dafür sind die krisen so furchtbar sie
waren und sind eigentlich die richtige
der richtige anlass werde es bei corona
gesehen nach anfänglichen
schwierigkeiten hat europa gut zusammen
gestanden und reagiert wir haben es bei
dem russischen krieg in der ukraine
gesehen dass europa sehr einig und
schnell gehandelt hat so muss europa
sich immer verhalten nicht das klein
klein und auch nicht diese
[Musik]
einzelnen staaten wie zum beispiel
ungarn wie zum beispiel viktor orban
erlauben immer in die suppe zu spucken
ihr kollege im europaparlament von der
cvp fraktion manfred weber der hat heute
gesagt das war vielleicht der letzte
warnschuss und er hat auch gesagt makro
ist wiedergewählt sein politisches
konzept aber ist gescheitert schließen
sich dem an
wir werden das sehr viel genauer wissen
im juni bei den parlamentswahlen denn
wir haben jetzt gesehen dass schon im
ersten wahlgang sich die stimmen sehr
stark konzentriert haben ich habe das
bei meinen sozialistischen kolleginnen
und kollegen gesehen die zum teil da
schon micron gewählt haben damit er auf
jeden fall in die stichwahl kommt und
das nicht am ende marine le pen gegen
den weit linken kandidatin enden würde
und wir werden im juni sehen wie sich
das wirklich verteilt da werden auch von
marine le pen wahrscheinlich einige
stimmen weg gehen zu dem schon erwähnten
ericsson aber auch zur valerie pecresse
zu den konservativen die jetzt ja
katastrophal abgeschnitten haben genauso
wie die sozialisten auch also das wird
noch mal neues bild und da sehen wir wie
die franzosen wirklich ticken anders als
jetzt bei der präsidentschaftswahl sie
haben gerade sozialisten angesprochen
ihre schwesterpartei in europa
1,75 prozent in der ersten runde was
löst das bei ihnen aus
ja das ist natürlich furchtbar dieses
dieser niedergang der geht jetzt schon
eine ganze weile gesagt wir haben einen
ähnlichen niedergang diesmal bei den
konservativen erlebt haben eine ganz
starke fokussierung auf makro le pen und
daneben auch noch den links weit links
außen stehenden kandidaten miller jean
gesehen das ist typisch für personen
waren wir werden sehen wie das jetzt bei
den präsidenten bei den parlamentswahlen
ist da werden sicherlich alle nochmal
noch mal gas geben und ich hunger dass
sich das dann etwas anders darstellt vor
bali sie haben gesagt vor diesem wahltag
der sieg in le pens ein sieg le pens
wäre eine horrorvorstellung das heißt
sie und viele andere in europa haben da
doch jetzt im laufe des wahlkampfs doch
relativ tief in den abgrund geguckt wäre
le pens sieht das ende der eu wie wir
sie aktuell erleben gewesen
ich glaube ja wir haben wie gesagt ja
schon einige die eigentlich an europa
der nationalstaaten wollen also 1 wo die
hauptstädte zu bestimmen haben und nur
einzelinteressen dann am ende eine rolle
spielen und eben nicht mehr das
gemeinsame interesse davon haben wir
schon genug wenn wir das in frankreich
noch gesehen hätten dann wäre die
deutsch-französische achse natürlich
gebrochen und wir hätten eine putin
freundin mit am tisch des europäischen
rates sitzen gehabt das wäre insgesamt
für die europäische union wirklich eine
katastrophe geworden also einfacher
haben werden und wirklich ein pro
europäer ja viel aufatmen also heute
auch bei katarina barley der
vize-präsidentin des europa-parlaments
formale vielen dank für das gespräch
heute abend singen
ein sieg von marine le pen wäre für
deutschland ein krasser einschnitt als
tramp im weißen haus oder der praxis
gewesen theo koll für uns in berlin was
bedeutet denn das ergebnis jetzt fünf
neue jahre makro für die deutsche
politik
ja also in berlin glaube ich hat cem
özdemir das stellvertretend für viele
formulierte schrieb dass ihm ein stein
vom herzen gefallen ist für die
bundesregierung heißt es einen engen
partner zu behalten unter le pen wäre
der deutsch französische motor sofort
verschrottet worden und das bedeutet
eine fortführung wichtiger
gemeinsamkeiten im ukraine krieg bei
rüstungsprojekten in unzähligen anderen
fragen gleichzeitig dürfte der
engagierte pro europäer makro für berlin
aber auch nicht nur ein einfacher
partner werden denn einerseits beträgt
er die französische staatsverschuldung
115% andererseits will man die
europäische 60 prozent grenze bei der
staatsverschuldung aufheben und fordert
zugleich mehr europa und der
bundeskanzler wird mit marco einen
durchaus talentierten konkurrenten um
die nummer 1 in europa erleben
2017 habe ich das vor ort erlebte hatte
angela merkel das ja noch ausgebremst
jetzt ist olaf scholz er den newcomer
überhaupt hat die bundesregierung und
die sie tragen der ampelkoalition im
moment ja ganz eigene sorgen darum
wortes erheblich in den eigenen reihen
theo und indirekt trifft das den kanzler
ja also wir gehen hier in eine spannende
politische woche der möglicherweise
gleich mehrfach im bundestag über die
lieferung schwerer waffen in die ukraine
abgestimmt werden wird die union hat
heute einen antrag vorgelegt in dem
gefordert wird dass aus den beständen
der bundeswehr in größtmöglichem umfang
und unverzüglich
rüstungsgüter zu liefern seien inklusive
schwerer waffen und der druck auf urlaub
scholz der kommt dabei nicht nur von der
union sondern auch aus den reihen der
eigenen ampelkoalition da sind viele
unzufrieden mit einer eher als zögerlich
empfundenen zeitenwende und mit der
zurückhaltung bei direkten
waffenlieferungen robert habeck hat uns
das heute hier im zdf schon angedeutet
da muss mehr kommen meinte er
also interessante woche vor uns theo
auch dafür herzlichen dank für diesen
kleinen ausblick an diesem sonntagabend
und damit sind wir bei weiteren
nachrichten heute und bei einer weiteren
wahl vorhin schon ganz kurz angesprochen
worden bei dem es auch um europa gegen
hannah christian auch in slowenien wurde
nämlich gewählt und zwar ein neues
parlament und nach ersten
teilergebnissen
zeichnet sich ein regierungswechsel ab
die liberalen freiheitsbewegung unter
quereinsteiger robert golog kommt
demnach auf rund 33 prozent die
regierende rechtsnationale partei sds
auf nur rund 25 prozent die wahl gilt
als richtungsweisend der derzeit
regierende ministerpräsident jantscher
ist ein enger verbündeter des ebenfalls
rechtsnationalen ungarischen
ministerpräsidenten orban sein
herausforderer golog trifft für eine
grüne energiewende ein
nach den sexismus vorwürfen innerhalb
der linken zieht die parteispitze nun
personelle konsequenzen
bereits im juni soll der komplette
vorstand neu gewählt werden angesichts
der schwierigen lage der linken sei der
parteivorstand überzeugt dass er ein
neues mandat des parteitags benötige
heißt es in einem vorstandsbeschluss
erst am mittwoch hatte die ko
vorsitzende susanne hennig welt so ihren
sofortigen rücktritt angekündigt
cdu-chef märz hat eine aufarbeitung der
deutschen russland politik der
vergangenheit angemahnt die außen und
sicherheitspolitik der letzten 20 jahre
stehe vor einem scherbenhaufen sagte
merz der bild am sonntag
auch in der union habe es schwere
versäumnisse gegeben etwa bei
entscheidungen zur ausrüstung der
bundeswehr
die kritik an spd altkanzler und gas
lobbyist gerhard schröder reißt nicht ab
nach schröders äußerungen in der new
york times bezeichnete ihn der cdu
politiker an marco wanderwitz auf
twitter als zitat bundeskanzler der
schande der vorsitzende der jungen union
tillmann kuban kritisierte eine russland
connection innerhalb der spd schröder
hatte sich zum ersten mal seit beginn
des ukraine kriegs zu wort gemeldet auch
zu einem möglichen rücktritt von seinem
posten bei russischen energiekonzernen
zurücktreten würde er nur wenn russland
den gashahn zudrehe mit einem solchen
szenario rechne er aber nicht
heute ist ostersonntag für die
orthodoxen christen in aller welt
natürlich auch in russland und natürlich
auch in der ukraine
die frohe botschaft der auferstehung
inmitten der schrecken des krieges
dieser irrsinn wird den russischen
militär kommandeuren und ihrem
präsidenten im kreml offenbar nicht klar
russlands wohl größter fernseh
entertainer allerdings sieht das jetzt
anders maxim gorki meldet sich mit bei
seinen abermillionen instagram followern
aus israel und sagt russland ist an so
vielen schrecklichen dingen schuld und
sagt immer es sei nicht schuld
vor zwei monaten hat wladimir putin den
angriff auf die ukraine befohlen
tausende tote millionen auf der flucht
zerstörte städte und dörfer die bilanz
ist verheerend und der krieg geht weiter
auch heute ralf panichi
lediglich der keller bietet ihr noch
etwas schutz seit wochen lebt oliver
koppel dort um sich vor russischen
angriffen zu schützen zusammen mit zwölf
weiteren menschen draußen in ihrem dorf
bei sharif im norden der ukraine steht
fast nichts mehr
wie es mir geht sehr nervös bin ich alle
hier sind nervös die osterfeiern bringen
keine freude ich weine viel was wir
erlebt haben kann man nicht vergessen
und dennoch der versuch ein wenig
normalität zu leben das backen des
traditionellen süßen osterkuchen pasqua
nach einem alten rezept ihrer großmutter
lässt sie sich nicht nehmen
überall in der ukraine finden an diesem
tag gottesdienste zum orthodoxen
osterfest stadt irgendwie selbst in dem
ort nahe kiew der zum sinnbild der
verbrechen in diesem krieg geworden ist
am morgen veröffentlichte präsident
selensky dieses video von ihm in der
käfer so viel kathedrale perfekt
produziert und mit einer botschaft die
mut machen soll
wir haben niemanden angegriffen also
gott gib uns schutz wir haben keine
anderen nationen zerstört also lasst uns
nicht zerstört werden wir haben keine
länder erobert also lasst nicht zu dass
andere uns erobern beschütze die ukraine
von osterfrieden an diesem sonntag keine
zeichen aufnahmen des russischen
verteidigungsministeriums veröffentlicht
heute vor allem in den stark umkämpften
gebieten im osten der ukraine wurde der
beschuss fortgesetzt
angriffe so das russische
verteidigungsministerium
die unter anderem verschiedene
waffenlager getroffen haben sollen
auch die ukrainische seite bestätigt
angriffe und dass es wieder tote gab
russland verstärkte zudem seine truppen
nördlich der ukraine zusätzliche
einheiten würden zusammengezogen auch
kurzstreckenraketen
auch soll es wieder schwere angriffe auf
das stark umkämpfte als auch stahlwerk
in mario pohl geben
in richtung mario pohl setzt der feind
den beschuss und die blockierung der
einheiten im industriekomplex fort
er führt luftangriffe durch auch von
langstreckenflugzeugen aus
eine rettung zumindest der hunderten
zivilisten die sich hier noch aufhalten
sollen scheiterte auch heute wieder so
die ukrainische seite
in kiew soll in den kommenden tagen
zahlreiche hochrangige gespräche
stattfinden neben der reise von
un-generalsekretär görisch ist es vor
allem der besuch von us aussenminister
blinken auf den viele hoffnungen ruhen
und der gerade jetzt in kiew ist
wir werden darüber berichten jetzt aber
erstmal weitere nachrichten von heute
und von sport und da blicken wir
zuallererst auf einen rekord sieger und
zwar an handball zum zwölften mal ist
der in der vereinsgeschichte hat der thw
kiel den deutschen handball pokal
gewonnen in einem packenden finale
bezwang die mannschaft von philipp h den
bundesliga tabellenführer ist dem
magdeburg mit 28 zu 21
zur fußball bundesliga da gab es heute
zwei begegnungen der vfl bochum verlor
gegen den fc augsburg mit 0 2 in berlin
traf hertha bsc auf den vfb stuttgart
das ergebnis zwei zu null
heute abend sind die preisträger der
internationalen laureus sports awards
bekanntgegeben worden einer der
preisträger ist robert lewandowski vom
deutschen meister bayern münchen in der
kategorie außergewöhnliche leistungen
auch gerald asamoah wurde prämiert
stellvertretend für die dokumentation
schwarze adler eine zdf-koproduktion die
in der zdf mediathek abrufbar ist
in dem gebäude sind ein hotel viele
apartments es gibt eine bar auf dem dach
mit blick über den potomac fluss die
erinnerung verblasst langsam an das was
dort
1972 passiert ist zu viele skandale
haben die usa hat washington dc seitdem
erlebt und dennoch als damals fünf
einbrecher im watergate komplex
verhaftet wurden und der name des
gebäudeensembles einer affäre ihren
namen gab die zum sturz des präsidenten
führte das bleibt stoff für hollywood
immer noch und immer wieder eine neue
packende polit serie erzählt das
watergate geflecht von verschwörung und
machtmissbrauch jetzt aus einer anderen
sicht julia roberts ist dabei
und maria nasa dass sich angesehen
1972 justizminister john mitchell und
ehefrau massa gehören zum engsten
regierungskreise in washington
mitchell soll präsident nixon mit allen
mitteln zur wiederwahl verhelfen während
die schillernde massa gerne in tv shows
und magazinen aus dem politischen
nähkästchen plaudert
ich habe vor langer zeit beschlossen
dass ich sage was ich denke und es ist
egal ob der präsident damit mir
übereinstimmt
in der zeit in der masse gelebt hat war
es sehr ungewöhnlich und auch nicht
gewollt dass frauen in der
öffentlichkeit ihre meinung deutlich
sagen so wie sie lässt hat vor allem
wenn die meinung der frau eine andere
war es die ihres ehemanns das ging gar
nicht
beide sind unaufhaltsam
für mitchell gespielt von sean penn der
maske kaum wieder zu erkennen ist wird
seine redselige ehefrau zum problem
denn er ist als wahlkampfmanager tief in
die watergate affäre verstrickt hat die
aufgeflogene abhöraktion beim
politischen gegner für nixon mit
organisiert
stehen sie hier nur zum spaß oder häufig
gestellt
massa muss zum schweigen gebracht werden
notfalls mit gewalt dagegen meine
fähigkeiten sie haben das telefon
abgestellt
vielleicht bekommt eine auszeit von
ihrem telefon ihnen auch misses mitchell
als sie mit dem skandal an die
öffentlichkeit gehen will wird sie
kurzerhand für verrückt erklärt viele
frauen in ihrem alter haben ab und an
paranoider episoden
tatsächlich gilt schon mit schluss
ehefrau martha heute als die erste
whistleblowerinnen die präsident richard
nixon ganz direkt für watergate
verantwortlich machte die er hatte lange
versucht die affäre zu vertuschen bevor
er schließlich zurücktreten musste massa
mittel aber wurde öffentlich verspottet
geriet in vergessenheit
wie viel haben wir aus unserer
geschichte gelernt und aus der immer und
immer wieder kehrenden korruption in der
politik es gehen so viele dinge auch
heute noch vorsichtig sind so
offensichtlich aber werden nicht
geahndet wir wollten diese geschichte
jetzt erzählen um uns daran zu erinnern
dass wir den menschen zu hören die die
wahrheit sagen wollen
in sieben folgen erzählt gast von dem
skurrilen ereignissen rund um watergate
herausragend julia roberts als die
widerspenstige mit
watergate filme haben es immer in sich
wer irgendwann mal den legendärsten von
ihnen gesehen hat oder präsident mit
robert redford und dustin hoffman als
reporter der washington post der konnte
danach gar nicht anders als journalist
zu werden was uns in der kommenden woche
beschäftigen wird hat lara wiedeking
jetzt für sie der heute journal ausblick
[Musik]
als kraftvolle stimme der ukraine wird
ab montag dass kiew symphony orchestra
durch sieben deutsche konzerthäuser
touren
die konzertreihe voice of you crane hat
seinen deutschland auftakt in dresden zu
den weiteren stationen gehören hamburg
wiesbaden und hannover
hände geschüttelt haben olaf scholz und
japans premier tische da schon beim g7
treffen am donnerstag will der
bundeskanzler seinen japanischen
amtskollegen in tokio treffen dabei soll
es neben dem ukraine krieg auch um die
rolle chinas gehen
die vergangenen zwei jahre bei der
gedenkmarsch an den holocaust nur
digital möglich diesen donnerstag wird
er traditionell wieder in auschwitz
stattfinden zum ersten mal nimmt eine
delegation aus den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten teil beim marsch der
lebenden erinnern tausende jüdinnen und
juden an die verbrechen der nazizeit und
jetzt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten
norden wechseln morgen sonne und wolken
meist bleibt es trocken sonst regnet es
oft teils mit gewittern dabei werden
zehn grad auf den ostseeinseln und 17
grad am oberrhein erreicht
auch am dienstag regnet es in der
südhälfte dann setzt sich aber immer
mehr die sonne durch die temperatur
steigert sich von 9 bis 16 grad am
dienstag auf 12 bis 22 grad am
donnerstag
22 grad das war unsere welt an diesem
sonntag wie im heute journal sind auch
morgen für sie da und zwar sehr gerne
und die nächsten nachrichten gibt es
hier gegen 0.30 heute express mit
christopher wehrmann ihnen noch einen
schönen abend tschüss
[Musik]